- [Gary] Really.
- [Sacha] Firstly, you are
incredible in Australia.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- Like we were the second row,
the energy that comes off you,
is just,
it's like you have an
aura that goes for miles.
- Thank you.
- You have this incredible
energy, that is.
- I think that most people
aren't as grateful as I am,
I really believe that,
I really think when I
think about my energy,
I think it's just gratitude, I really do,
perspective.
- Yeah.
- Like I just,
I really struggle, I really struggle with
being upset about what everybody
spends their time being upset about.
Like losing an account
or,
or
having somebody make
fun of you, just like,
like it's just really hard
to get upset about things
other than
the health of the 11
people I give a shit about.
- [Sacha] Oh, was it.
- And so everything
else, it's just binary,
it's that's what's
worth being upset about,
and then everything else is awesome,
ya know.
- [Sonya] Love that.
We've been watching so
much of your content,
you look at people walking in this room,
and they play it so cool ya know,
they're going oh, I'm cool for school,
I couldn't wait, I was like
bursting to get in here,
and be like.
- This is it.
- We're so,
like we've come from Australia.
- It's so cool, I can't believe how cool
this room has become to
like entrepreneurs and so,
makes me so happy.
- This is iconic yeah.
- Yeah.
- So, you know what we're like,
we're like the 40 plus year
old people who started,
ya know, a couple years ago.
- I get it.
- Like entrepreneurs, yeah,
we've both been speakers
in schools and universities
around Australia for like 17 years.
- Yes.
- Teenagers.
- And parents.
So, we create content for parents.
- Yes.
- We create content for teenagers
to help them get through their,
ya know, their really
tough time in their lives.
- I love it.
- I talk about drugs,
alcohol, safe partying,
night clubbing, ya know when they go out,
keeping themselves safe.
- And I talk about Crerrl;j bullying,
cyber bullying stress management,
body image, teamwork, leadership.
- Love it.
- Yes.
- It's awesome.
- Let's go, let's get right into it.
- So, let's go.
So, alright, so, tell
us, tell us who you are.
- Yeah.
- And what your story is.
- I'm Gary Vaynerchuk,
my story is a classic
American immigrant story,
I was born in Belarus in
the former Soviet Union,
I came here when I was a little kid,
I lived in a studio apartment,
the size of the office we're
in, with six family members,
seven family members, depending
on the day of the week,
extremely humble beginnings,
didn't speak the language, got picked on,
because I didn't speak the language,
but then I had an amazing childhood,
we, very quickly my dad
worked his butt off,
and became a manager of a liquor store,
which allowed us, and
afforded us to move out
to Edison, New Jersey, and there
I became
an entrepreneur,
I played plenty of whiffle
ball, and Nerf foot ball,
and ya know, a lot of games,
but I spent, and got, in hindsight,
I spent an ungodly amount
of time on car washes,
on lemonade stands, on raking leaves,
on singing Christmas carols,
anything to make a dollar,
anything,
and so, and that led to baseball cards,
which then led to a very
successful entrepreneurial
career in the wine business,
which is my dad's business,
in a, in investing,
ya know, Tumblr, and
Twitter, and Uber stocks
are hanging around here,
and I invested in those pretty IPO,
and now we're sitting in VaynerMedia,
ya know, which is a 150 million dollar
agency,
and then obviously along the way,
I've also built out a personal brand,
that's led to what's about to be
my 5th New York Time's bestselling book,
and.
- Crushing it.
- And a career where I'm getting,
the fact that I get paid more
to give a one hour speech today,
than I made for the whole year
just
ya know
15 years ago,
it's just
scary exciting,
and so, that's been fun,
and as you guys know,
have really inspired an
interesting conversation
amongst a lot of people,
a slightly, ya know,
a slightly different take I
think on what has motivated,
ya know, I don't think of myself
as a motivational speaker,
but I'm clearly a personality that is
been able to get people to get results.
- Yeah.
- Which you can't imagine
how proud of I am.
- Yeah,
well, what kind of teenager were you?
- I was a great teenager, my mom,
I might even be called Perfectly Parented,
so, it's interesting
to hear what you guys.
- Wow.
- This is awesome.
- So, I'm writing a book
called Perfectly Parented,
and it's the perspective of a kid,
who feels his parents
perfectly parented him.
My mom and dad,
so, I, I never did any,
I mean, I did nothing wrong
except get bad grades,
so, I never disrespected anybody,
I never
did cliche drugs and alcohol stuff,
I was,
I was the nicest kid.
I was friends with
everybody in my high school,
I worked every minute,
I went to like 7 high
school parties in my life,
ya know, I just worked,
I like, helped around the
house cause I was the oldest,
I was,
I was
a ridiculously good kid,
yet,
I wasn't like a square, or ya know, like
meaning I had fun, I enjoyed it,
like, my high school
years were very simple,
I worked every minute,
or which was the happiest moments of time,
whether it was doing baseball card shows,
selling at flea markets,
or working in my dad's liquor store,
or
I
was in school being miserable.
I didn't play sports.
I played tennis for two years,
but I barely played sports
I
I didn't chase girls,
for the most part,
like, I just
was very focused on being an entrepreneur,
from a very young age,
and I was obsessed with
not making my mom upset.
- I love that.
Let me tell you,
seeing as I'm a mum.
- Yeah.
- Ya know, I wanted
- It's just true,
like I, my mom guilted
me into being a great
child, and a great teenager,
and I think that's what
I do to my employees.
- How, how?
- Yeah.
- By providing so much love,
and, and support, that the
fear is letting them down,
guilting.
Iris was gonna leave after
working here for a year,
that was her plan, that was her thoughts,
but she's still here,
because it's better to be
here, than it's not to be here.
- Well, a lot of teenagers
actually disconnect
from their parents.
- Because their parents are screwing up,
their parents are doing the wrong thing,
their parents care about
themselves not their kids.
Parents are struggling out there,
because they're insecure,
and they're parenting their children
based on the judgment of other parents,
not based on putting their kids
in this position to succeed.
- So, you never disconnected
from you parents,
at any time.
- I was reconnect with
my parents right now,
I love them so much,
I wanna live with my parents now.
(Sonya and Sacha laugh)
But you have to understand
why, my mom's entire framework
was
supporting me
not
she was in a cocoon,
my mom didn't give a shit,
what another parent thought about
me.
- So, how does that happen, how did she?
- Self confidence.
- Passed it down to you.
- Where does that come from for you.
- I don't know, because my
mom lost her mom at five.
- Right.
- She grew up in Soviet Russia,
which is a very negative
place, it was just in her.
She was a, it was a DNA trait.
- Yeah.
- Maybe it was overcorrection
for not having a mom,
she wanted to the best,
but I haven't really deeply
psychoanalyzed my mom yet,
but
ya know,
she
she,
boy did she do a good job,
and I think, ya know, again,
I think the reason I'm
popular, as a personality
is cause I'm better to my
audience than anybody else.
- Yeah.
- I don't wanna trick you into anything.
- Mmm.
- That's what you feel on stage.
- Yeah.
- You know why you felt it?
- Why?
- It's cause I genuinely want you to win,
and there's nothing else,
because it's a legacy,
it's like being a parent,
you being successful
is an incredible indication of me.
- Mmhmm.
- But I think most people that
are motivational speakers,
personalities or running distances,
are,
are selfishly in it for
what's in it for them,
in the short term.
- Yeah,
well, it's almost like this thing
as I always say I'm just the vessel
for the information to come out,
to be able to get to you.
- But I'm also selfish,
like I don't think I'm some altruistic
kind of like, ya know, vessel,
I'm selfish, my selfishness
comes in the form of legacy.
- [Sacha] Mmmhmm.
- I have a funny feeling you guys aren't
flying from Australia to
New York for most people.
- Seriously not.
- Well, we are doing it for a
lot of other people as well.
- Yes, I'm sure.
- But we're also doing it for
us, because it feels good,
and feels great to be here.
- No, no, what I mean is you're
not gonna get dragged out.
- Ah Yes.
- Somewhere, I understand.
what I mean is, basically
my very simple thesis is,
I will win.
- Yes.
- If I have the Delta between
being financially successful,
and having the most
people come to my funeral.
- Yeah.
- I have no interest in building a
1400 billion dollar empire,
and having four people at my funeral.
I would
much rather
do
400 million,
and have 40,000 people
show up to my funeral.
- Yeah.
- Mmm.
- I think legacy is far more
attractive than currency,
and,
and that's what my mom created,
like, she, she took, she gave
up the short term judgment,
I was a D and F student,
Tyler, is my report card coming?
- [Tyler] Yeah.
- Good, I'm gonna hang
that next somewhere here.
- Oh, fantastic.
- I was a D and F student,
ya know, what D and F student's
get from other parents,
rolling eyes, judgment,
and condescending comments,
but my mom raised the biggest
winner, in that high school.
- Yeah,
multi million.
- So, how are instilling these values
into your kids right now?
What are you actually doing?
- Listening.
They're five and eight, I'm listening.
- We have four and nine.
- Great, I'm listening.
I've made zero judgements so far,
on how I'm doing that,
I am just watching them,
the way you become a great parent,
and put your child in
a position to succeed
is you build the road
map and the blueprint
in reaction to who they are
not your personal
ideological wants and needs.
I'm watching them.
I'm seeing what comes natural to them,
what they love, and what they don't love,
what they're good at,
what they're not good at,
and then I will create
supportive infrastructure around that,
but right now,
pure love,
and pure support while
deep lines in the sand,
of what is humanly right and wrong.
Being nice is a line in the sand,
trying to from resemblance
of compassion and empathy
is a line in the sand,
you can't, I don't know how much you
can instill empathy and compassion,
but
I'm trying to in a subtle way.
- Mmhmm.
- Those are things that I care about,
I do not give a shit
about what grade level
they're reading at.
- Mmmhmm.
- Yeah.
- Mmm.
- Or, I'm not overthinking
that they're a little spoiled,
you can't fabricate environment,
I grew up with nothing,
they're growing up with something.
- Yeah.
- I'm not gonna be able to trick that.
- What am I not gonna buy them a toy,
while their going to the
Hamptons for the summer,
like, ya know, you don't, you don't,
you don't fabricate environment,
so,
I'm in the listening business right now.
- So, we're massive on gratitude,
and we're trying to use that
with our children, you know.
- Yes.
- In as many ways as we can.
- Whether that be on the way to school,
give me five things that
you're grateful for today.
- That's right.
- You know, those kinds of things,
you're getting into their
head from a young age.
- Yes, yes.
- What are you doing,
because you're the king
of gratitude and empathy,
and that sort of stuff,
how do you pair that with
slap it in your face honesty,
which is just an awesome combo.
- I think ya know, look
I'm in a great spot,
like, I don't do anything,
my kids are gonna watch my
YouTube videos, very soon.
- Yeah.
- This is already done,
like it's an ethos, it's a living,
like I think the tactics matter,
and I respect the, but I'm
not, I'm not doing that.
- Yeah.
- But I do think it's a good idea.
- Like, I think that's clever,
and when you were just saying,
oh, shit I should do that,
but I won't, because that's not what I do.
- Yeah.
- Everybody needs to do what they do,
but
I'm doing it,
ya know, as, to me what scares me
is when somebody does
tactics and doesn't live it.
If you're actually grateful,
then that tactic is
phenomenal, it's a reinforcer.
- Mmm.
- But if you're not,
and you're doing it as an optic,
which is what so many parents do,
parents do a lot of things
they don't believe in,
they do what they think
they're supposed to be doing,
and they get caught up in a rat race of,
I'm telling you this
is what, what took me,
until I was one, but
even more importantly,
until I spent time with a lot of them,
now that I have kids,
I spend time with 'em,
I'm like,
here's a good one,
do you know that I didn't
really understand why
parents put bumper stickers on their cars
of the universities
that their kids went to.
I didn't realize that that was something
that made them feel good about themselves.
- Yes.
- Look at me, I'm the parent
of a kid that went to Princeton.
The thought for me to have my self esteem
wrapped up in my kid's
accomplishments is so foreign.
I think that's a loser.
- Yes.
- It's just ego.
- Yep.
- It's just ego, and it's insecurity,
and it's trying to paint a picture,
and so, to me, ya know, I
know who I am as a human,
and what my values are,
and how I think people,
like how I would, ya know,
here's what I'm thinking about,
I,
it's less about I'm gonna do,
It's more about what I'm
gonna do in reaction to,
so.
- Well, they're gonna soak it in from you.
- 100%.
- Without having to do the
one two strategies, yeah.
- And I'm an unique situation,
I over index with young
kids, because of my style.
- Yeah.
so, ya know my kids are
only seven or ten years away
from their friends thinking I'm cool.
- Yeah.
- And when, ya know,
when your friends think something's cool,
you think it's cool.
- Yeah.
- So, I'm gonna have a
bigger impact on my kids
through the eyes of their friends,
and what that means to them.
- Yep.
- My kids are gonna listen to me more,
because their friends listen to me,
- Yep.
- Than them listening to me.
- So,
with the dumpster video, yeah.
- Yes.
Our four year old is, is watching that,
he calls you Gary vegan truck, yeah,
cause he can't say Vaynerchuk.
(Sonya and Sacha laugh)
And he's all over it.
Where did that come from,
cause we use it all the time,
we show it.
- The dumpster one?
- We've shared it like a 1,000 times.
- I was on a flight, I'll never forget it,
that was outside of an airport.
I was on a flight, and two people in a row
DM'ed me something on
Insta, I'm a listener,
I'm a counter puncher,
you know I'm a very interesting character,
I'm confusing, because
I talk all the time,
I interrupt people,
so, everybody thinks
all I wanna do is talk,
but what's interesting is
I spend the majority of my time listening,
nobody reads their comments more than me,
nobody,
speaks and adjusts on the fly
based on how the audience
is reacting more than me,
nobody does that, like I
believe in that, in me,
I think that's why,
so, I'm listening, so, what
happened, I was listening,
I read two separate emails or DM's,
or Twitter posts of
like, some insecurities
from two of my audience members,
something hit me of like,
of a seed of like, this is,
like, I hear it all the time,
but something in those two
in a row got me motivated,
I got off the airplane, and
I was like let's film this,
and I just happened to see a dumpster,
and thought it was a funny scene,
and ya know, referenced
trash and high school,
and like, just had a moment,
ya know, I have,
a lot of times I know when I'm,
I can't predict virality,
but I always know when
I have something in me,
if I can get them to film it,
that it's going to do well.
- Good instinct.
- So, we're working long hours,
you're working on long hours,
how, do you ever feel guilty,
that if you're not being.
- Never.
- Not going to do something.
- Nope, nope.
- You don't feel guilty,
and what would you say to a parent,
that maybe feeling guilty,
that they're not able to
get to all the school plays.
- I would tell them,
I would tell them who gives
a shit of what Gary V thinks
and you do you.
- Yeah.
- You live your life.
I'm just a little practical about this.
I think it's more important
to love your child
unconditionally and support them
than to be at every event.
So, a lot of parents go to every event,
but their undermining
their children's happiness,
and self confidence,
because they themselves are insecure.
So, to me it's just checking a box.
So, what you're a big shot,
cause you went to every
little league game,
but meanwhile you're an alcoholic,
or you're insecure,
and you're trying to suppress your child,
or you tell them that they can't do,
or you make them over practice baseball,
because it makes you feel good
if they get a scholarship around baseball,
so I much rather miss every other play,
and recital and ball game,
but make my kids emotional ninjas,
that's my choice on this issue.
- You had no issues to
bring into your parenting.
Cause you're parenting amazingly.
- No shit.
- So.
- And so is my wife to be honest.
So, now you're fucking
off to the races, right.
- Yeah.
- Because people listening to me,
I'm penetrating,
like, I, ya know why, cause
I'm speaking the truth,
you and I we're doing a show right now,
I'm bringing up thematics in parenting,
that I'm struggling to
see people talk about,
cause I'm getting to the part
that nobody wants to talk about,
the truth,
the truth is you're
struggling with parenting,
cause,
it's all about you.
- Absolutely.
- Do you know how many parents?
You're saying that you want
your kid to be well rounded,
and so, they're in violin and sports,
and this that,
but it's because you wanna go cycling,
and have a coffee with your girlfriends,
that's the truth.
- Mmm.
- Yep.
- So, either we're gonna
talk about the truth or not,
you're saying that you're gonna pay,
what a great dad I am,
I'm sending Ricky to the
best baseball camp this year,
and I'm working hard to pay for it.
Mmmm, mnmm, mmmm, mmmm.
You like bragging that little Ricky's
a great fuck'in baseball
player, it's selfish.
I'm just not about that.
- Mmmm.
- Not with my audience,
it's about them, and definitely obviously,
not with my kids, it is about them,
and I'll get mine in the residuals,
my mom is like walking
around, like a champ, like
my mom and I talk every
other morning, every morning,
every ya know, sometimes
I can go a week without talking to her,
so, it's not even like,
ya know, it's not like this cliche
I talk to my mom everyday, we're talking,
I'm talking to my mom right now,
like, we're like that.
- Yeah.
- You understand.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And when I talk to her
everyday, she just like,
she just thinks it's the greatest,
she's like, like, she's like,
all these, all these Russian
moms are hitting me up.
(Sonya and Sacha laugh)
Ya know, like she's the,
like, she's getting, like everything
gets paid off properly,
she's an all time mom,
and I was meant to be
somebody who has an audience,
who that then gets to tell everybody
she was an all time mom,
and that's a big deal.
- Do you know, we've
interviewed so many people,
and, and it's been really common thread
through successful people
that we've spoken to,
that they've had these
difficult sort of, ya know,
childhood teenage years,
and they've had struggles,
and they've come from this,
and you're the first one.
- Well, I'll tell you what.
- Had none of that.
- I'll tell you what.
I think people sometimes search
to create an origin story,
I think people fabricate their struggles.
- Yep.
- Cause it's romantic.
- And I also think it's in the edges,
I think you either are
very much struggling,
but I think there's a lot of
people who are very successful,
who have remarkable high school years.
- Yep.
- And I'm one of them,
and I think, there's a lot of people,
as I'm talking to you,
I'm thinking about a lot of kids,
who,
a lot of times in immigrant families,
cause when you have a tight family,
that's really a big factor,
who had great
childhoods,
and are crushing it,
because they're blindly self confident,
I'm blindly self confident, my mom
brainwashed me into
believing I'm the best,
and I just believed,
I really believe it,
like, I, in a world of Elon Musk,
and Mark Zuckerberg, and
Jeff Bezos, and Mark Cuban,
and all these incredible
entrepreneurs, in a world of that,
and incredible executives
like Cheryl Sandberg,
and Ariana Huffington, in a world of that,
I'm completely utterly convinced,
as I sit here with you today,
that I will be the alpha
winner of this generation,
because I won't make the most money,
but I will make the most money,
and impact the most people,
you can't win this thing without both.
- Yeah.
I can be quite fluffy and
amazing, and make everybody,
but if I didn't have the
business success well then,
no, you wouldn't look up to me that way.
- Yep.
- But I think I'm gonna win.
- So, we have this thing,
we don't do anything unless it's fun,
there's has to be an element of fun.
- That's cool.
- In everything we do right.
So, if you're having the best fun,
it looks like you're
having the best fun ever,
so, what's the most fun
part about what you do,
and what's the toughest part?
- They're one and the same,
the most fun and the toughest part
is I was built for the masses.
- Yeah.
- I was built
to be who
I am,
I'm
absolutely, gonna have 100%
awareness in the world,
everybody on this world, as
long as I don't die too young
for some reason,
in 40 years every person on this earth
will know who I am,
I was built for that,
there are very few
people that achieve that,
I will achieve it,
and,
it's, there's a lot of reasons,
there's a lot of people
who are uber famous,
before that weren't
known in Africa or Asia,
because of the way media worked,
but the way media works now,
I will be known everywhere,
that's the best and most fun,
but it's also the hardest,
because when you are for everyone,
it takes away from what
you have left for
yourself and your family.
- Yeah
- That's it, that is my gift and my curse.
- So, that's.
- And I know it,
and,
ya know, you kind of like, you know,
it's not like you let go
of the steering wheel,
but sometimes you just understand it.
- So, how do you?
- But I don't beat myself up about it.
- Yeah.
- Because a parents job is to put their,
what is the binary line of being a parent,
put your kid in the best position
to have a happy, healthy successful life.
- That's all there is.
- That is not showing up to
every one of their events.
- That's all there is.
- What are we talking about here,
people are playing in the fucking
bullshit,
we're training on the bullshit,
we're talking about commodity stuff,
no kid's gonna need you,
if the parent was playing in the clouds.
Parents are playing in the dirt,
minutia.
- Mmm.
- And it's all predict about them
listening,
if you watch your child for seven years,
and you're obsessed about that,
you know how many parents
parent all three of their kids
the same way,
do you know how crazy that is?
- Yeah.
Absolutely.
- So, it's all about selfishness
and insecurity at the parent level.
So, I'm not gonna concede to the current
state of political correctness.
It's not gonna be considered
politically correct in three years.
You know how many,
you know how many parents are
drawing a line in the sand,
that I'm not gonna
reward this bad behavior,
and they think like that's
the most important thing,
without realizing how
this actually all works,
why are a lot of rich
kids spoiled and shitty,
and why are a lot of rich kids
like, you can't believe
that they're super rich,
and have, it was the parenting,
it was the framework,
it was the experience,
it was the environment,
there's a million
variables that go into it.
Parents are beating themselves up,
like, they're judgeing themselves.
- Mmm.
- Just step back.
- Yeah.
- Gotta, gotta look way bigger than that,
like, I love debating this with parents,
because I win every time,
here's why, we're selective,
like, any parents that's
like listening right now,
it's like, you're wrong about that Gary,
I'm like, cool, let's sit down and talk,
and let me spend one
hour, tell me everything,
well, like, well you don't,
you don't feed your kids very well,
and that might be somebody
else's number one,
I'm like wait, you let your
kids drink soda everyday,
that's somebody else's,
you gotta read well.
- Mmm.
- That's somebody, like, everyone, right,
there's like 47 things that
people think is the most,
music.
- Mmmm.
- Yeah.
- The fuck.
- Yes.
- Again, great, but I
know a ton of parents,
who make their kids do music,
so that they have to
be with an instructor,
so, they can go do something.
It's not that they believe
the musical skill set will set them free.
- Yeah.
- It's just that, it's
just an emotional gain,
it's not a physical gain,
and so to me, it's just getting
kids in the right mindset,
teaching them very basic things,
like kindness and gratitude,
and,
and work ethic.
- What about house hold chores, like.
- Yeah, I mean.
- Ya know.
- Again, again, again,
we'd never judge somebody else
thinking that's important,
but again, it's a tactic.
- Mmm.
- Mmmhmm.
- It's like, to me it's the next step,
which is like, yes,
but like, I'm not scared
to rip off the bandaid,
one can say gradually get
them into being a 14 year old,
that has a job, and chores help them,
I actually agree with
that, that makes sense.
- Yeah.
- I'm also not scared
of buying them everything in the world,
and then walking in on
their 14th birthday,
and saying, and by the way,
14's an arbitrary number,
it can be 13, it can 16,
but picking some moment,
that I feel good about,
and saying I'm not giving
you shit, and now you work,
and they'd be like you fucked me,
because,
(Sacha and Sonya laugh)
you know, you gave me everything,
but I know that if I
can do that somewhere,
two to three years before of college,
four years before college,
during college, that
they'll be on their way,
they just have to know
that they have to do
to get what they want,
and to me I don't mind if I screwed them,
or if I gradually put them into it,
because guess what, in
life, both are gonna happen.
- Correct.
- In life,
you'll have fort,
when you lose a parent,
some people lose their parent,
brrriiiibriiiii, hello,
and it's your sibling
crying, mom died, right,
others, mom gets diagnosed, and
takes four and a half years.
In life, some things are gradual.
- Yep.
- Some things are sudden.
- So, to me it's just preparing,
all these parents trying to
prepare their kids for life,
by touching everything and
anything, everything, and,
it's so fucking,
it's,
everybody who's a parent right now,
will go down
generally
in a 100 years
will be viewed upon as the
worst generation of parents
in the history of man kind.
We are doing a terrible collective job,
and there are hundreds of millions,
there's tens of millions
of phenomenal parents,
unfortunately,
the
global,
and obviously, this is
not the case in Venezuela,
this is not the case
in Syria, but globally,
things have been very good
for the last 50-67 years,
World War II is a long time ago,
the black plague is a long time ago,
right.
- Yep.
- It's a long time ago.
We have prospered as a race, for so long,
that it has now forced
parents to care about things
that don't actually matter.
- Mmm.
- It's not parent's fault,
I'm not at the current parents,
it's the macro effect of prosperity.
- Mmm.
Our great grandparents
were good at parenting,
cause they didn't have time to worry about
play dates, they were worried
about bombs dropping on heads,
they were worried about the depression,
they were worried about different things,
if you're a third generation
Australian or American parent,
or your eastern European,
western Europe parent,
on a macro, there's a lot of good,
so, you've now gotten into the fuck'in
third generation of prosperity,
so, that means we're soft.
- Yeah.
- That's real, here's what I would say.
I would never tell anybody how to parent,
period, let's start, I've been doing that
for this whole conversation.
Let me make everybody
understand we're just,
I'm answering a question.
- Absolutely, yeah.
- Yeah, I have zero interest
in telling how somebody to parent,
here's what I would say,
there's enough in the
system right now to show,
that the way we've kind of been doing it
for the last 15 to 20 years
has some cracks in the armor.
- Yep.
Parents would rather blame
social media for suicide
than the macro parenting trends.
- Yep, yep.
- Ya know, why did kids used to not,
why did kids used to not
have suicide be such an issue
well, it's because we treated bullying,
and winning and losing differently.
Let me tell you what
1974 us told their kids
when they got bullied at school,
deal with it,
what are we doing, we're in it,
which makes them feel
like they can't handle it.
Now,
do I think us parenting is the only reason
there's suicide rates up, of course not,
there's a million
variable, modern medicine,
diet,
information,
but
it's not social media.
- Mmm.
- Like, and we wanna keep
demonizing new technologies,
because we don't wanna
face our own issues,
so, what I would say
is I scrutinize myself
as a parent everyday,
and I don't think enough
people are doing that.
- It's cool that you say that.
- Ya know.
- Yeah.
- I think we wanna say
it's anybody but our fault.
- Full responsibility for everything.
- Full responsibiltiy.
- Yeah.
- 100%.
- Your kids struggling
right now in something,
that's your fault.
- Yep.
- Whether it's his or her fault,
whether it's somebody else's fault,
it's a great strategy to think it's yours,
whether it's true or not.
- Yep.
So, let's say.
- Gotta go Ty.
- Let's say.
- Two minutes.
- Let's say I'm a teenager.
- Yes.
- And my parents have let
me win on battle ship.
- Yes.
- And let me win.
- Stop blaming them, because that's what,
every teenager's running,
I get every DM, my fucked
me, they made it so,
I love this, they made it so easy for me,
like, my parents fucked me,
they made it so easy for me,
now, I'm struggling, I'm like, alright,
like,
deal with it,
we're treating teenagers
like three years olds,
instead of, like we're
going down instead of up.
- One of the most powerful things.
- Hey,
Sally, 14 years old,
from,
ya know,
the gold coast,
ya know, like,
you,
that's what happened,
here's a lot of other
things that happened.
- Yeah.
- And you're pretty,
you're good at sports,
you're not pretty, you're
not good at sports,
you're good at math, you're bad a math,
like, it's your life.
So, now what, you can spend
all your energy dwelling,
and blaming or you can realize,
that if you're capable of
taking on responsibility,
and going forward right
now you will win in life.
Now, that's heavy shit for a 15 year old.
Cause I ya know, I see
it go over their head,
plenty of times, but here's my point,
that's the right answer,
and more importantly,
if one out of every four 'em take it,
you're making an impact.
- Mmmhmm.
- I think we, this is the
difficulty for you guys,
making a message consumable to more,
usually means that it's
not impacting anyone.
- Really.
- Yep.
- This is the,
if you ask me, what I would,
without knowing anything about you.
- Yeah.
- What would be my intuition,
that if you said hey, come and analyze us,
I would say without knowing anything,
because it's 99.9% of what's
happening in the world,
as you go through it,
everybody tries to find that Mendoza line,
that can affect as many
people as possible,
without realizing that
then it gets too vanilla,
and it's not doing what
they want for anybody,
I'd rather
impact one out of every 17 teenagers,
to meaningfully change,
than 0 out of 17 by
pandering and wavering,
in a couple places to make
it seem more consumable,
it's tough.
You see where I'm going.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- I think that's why that
so many teenagers get us,
because we're doing that,
we're keeping it really real.
- And so, what I would tell
you is go even further.
- Mmmm.
Well, that's the, that's the next step.
- Go
one step further,
whatever you believe in,
that you're milking down,
go harder.
- Mmm.
- Because the only reason you're not
is your worried about what's
coming back where you,
when you go there,
and it could come in a million ways,
they won't get it,
which is nice, to think,
or mmm, that would be
tough for parents to hear,
or tough for kids to hear,
like it's one or the other,
I think that's the truth,
your truth and your opinion,
at its strength is its purest
form, not watered down.
- Mmmm, yeah.
- Yep.
- You wanna help us out?
- Alright.
- With all of our heart, Gary,
to the gratitude that is
full, like so much it is
bursting out, we wanna thank you.
- Thank you guys.
- For this time.
- Thanks for having me.
- Thank you for having us.
- No worries, thank you.
- Thank you for that gold.
- Thank you, you got it.
- Thank you.
(upbeat music)